thought i would talk about the very
strange cloud formation in this rather
beautiful picture taken on the norfolk
coast a week or so back their technical
name amongst cloud people is they're
called fluctus clouds but amongst
physicists they're called kelvin
helmholtz clouds and the reason why
they're called kelvin helmholtz clouds
is they illustrate a phenomenon called
the kelvin helmholtz instability uh
discovered by
lord kelvin and hermann von helmholtz in
the mid 19th century
i'm going to call them hook clouds okay
call them what you like kind of like you
know breaking waves maybe oh yeah i mean
you're right that they're curl over it
turns out it's a very common phenomenon
i mean you see it in clouds from time to
time but actually it's the same physics
that if you have wind blowing over water
it's why you get ripples appearing on
the surface of the water you see these
kind of kelvin helmholtz instabilities
in the cloud patterns on jupiter
[Music]
on the sun
[Music]
if you have a jet of material coming out
of the center of a galaxy and it starts
to wiggle around that's probably this
kelvin helmholtz instability as well
it's basically wherever you have two
streams of material traveling at
different speeds this instability will
kick in
let me draw your picture two streams of
stuff and they're just traveling at
different speeds but just for simplicity
we'll stow one going that way and one
going that way it could be one still and
the other moving but they just have to
be moving relative to each other
an instability is something where if
something starts to grow it will
continue to grow so if you start with a
little perturbation it just becomes a
bigger and bigger and bigger
perturbation and it turns out there is
this thing called the kelvin helmholtz
instability which will kick in in this
case so let me draw the same thing again
but with just the beginnings of kind of
an instability in the middle
it's a tiny i mean it can be very very
small and it's just a question of you
know will it go away again in which case
nothing happens or will it keep growing
and growing and growing in which case
it's interesting so what happens in this
case is if you look at the air flowing
here
you can see it's the same kind of volume
of air is moving all the way along here
but you can see here it's kind of its
passage gets a little bit constricted
there it gets wider there it's
constricted again
in the place where it's constricted in
order to get the same amount of air
through it has to go faster okay so the
airflow here becomes faster
to get through and actually here there's
more space so the airflow below actually
becomes lower
it doesn't have to go so fast the
material traveling over the top of this
bump here is actually traveling faster
than the
material below and there's this effect
this thing called the bernoulli effect
it's the same thing that makes airplanes
wings have lift which is where air is
traveling faster there's a decrease in
the pressure that's why with an air of
foil with a hair going over the top of
it the air travels further and therefore
it travels faster and therefore the
pressure decreases
and that causes the wing to go up so we
have the same phenomenon here we have
lift like that the air here is
travelling faster than the air here
which means the pressure here goes down
so the net effect of that is that then
this bit gets tugged up because the
pressure above it is lower and the
pressure below it is higher
and similarly down here there's a
decrease in pressure here and that means
that this bit gets pulled that way and
so you can see that what was a little
ripple here is now starting to grow and
then the last thing that hams is as this
thing grows of course it's going to get
kind of swept along by the air flowing
this way so it'll actually end up being
cooled over that way
that's the phenomenon you see in these
clouds right the little thing started to
grow up there it grew bigger and then it
got caught up in the flow above and got
pushed over that way
and so those little kind of horse head
shapes that appear here are basically
this kelvin helmholtz instability of the
instability first growing upwards and
then getting pushed along with the air
flow above horse head clouds that's an
even better name but nice yes
[Music]
so there is the common homework
instability
[Music]
for an extra video showing how this
experiment's done click on the links on
the screen or down in the video
description
and we have another 60 symbols video
about stripy clouds this time
or to really complete your cloud fix why
not check out this objectivity video
about the so-called father of cloud
studies
there's a guy you'd want to make a cloud
resembling a lock of hair or a feather
yeah okay